hello
and welcome to uh our simply learn
leadership webinar what does it take to
be part of a global marketing team today
our guest is sandeep menon he's a senior
marketing director of google
and our host for today is mark moran
the chief marketing officer of simply
learn before i introduce
mark to introduce sandeep i'd like to
give you a few instructions on how to
use
the webinar controls in webex
we will be logging your questions from
the q a box so
use that question mark button to access
that
ask your question we will keep track of
it and
mark and sandeep will address that in
the q
a later in the session uh he may
they may take a few questions live
during
the broadcast and in the chat window
you can also contact us use all
panelists
so that we all see it and we will be
logging those as well
and without further ado i will
turn it over to mark to introduce
sandeep
hi everyone um welcome to our webinar
today thank you very much for
attending and for your interest um we're
hoping to have a really lively
discussion i'm thrilled to have sandeep
joining us today sandeep is
a 13 plus year veteran of google
with uh steadily uh more senior roles he
presently leads
the global marketing efforts for uh
google payments
as well as google play across chrome
android and other platforms uh he
previously was a country marketing
uh director in india um and again has
had
sort of steadily increasing roles um
internationally
uh now runs the international team uh
from uh google's headquarters here in
mountain view
uh prior to all that uh some some time
at sap
and oracle way back when uh he comes
from uh nba from
insead and
karnataka which uh of course is uh where
bangalore is where simply learns
headquarters is
so um sandeep it's really uh great to
have you aboard we appreciate you taking
the time
i know you've got a very busy life and
then
quite a global operation um that you're
running
um so um thank you thank you thank you
for inviting me
i'm looking forward to this discussion
yeah great and um
you know so we're gonna we're gonna talk
uh a
chunk about global and what what sort of
global means but
um i think uh you know as as
the saying says think globally act
locally so i think we'll
begin by sort of generally talking about
marketing and marketing career
progression um and and then sort of
expand expand out from there and
talk about some of the sort of extra
challenges and opportunities with
managing
global teams or being a marketer is
trying to address a global
uh audience um so i think what what
would be you know sort of great is just
sort of
talk start a little bit with your kind
of career
progression and and background and um
uh you know how you kind of got to where
you are now
okay i'll try to do that justice so um
like many many folks um
from india um at least of my generation
i started off
i studied engineering mechanical
engineering um and
my first job was as a software company
i'm
initially developing banking software
right so very different from the
marketing role that i have right now
um post that um i moved on to sap
where um i had a real interest in the
business side of stuff while i loved
technology
um what really interested me was how you
can bridge technology
uh with the business side and how you
can actually
develop products but also kind of bring
them to market which is why i made a
shift to product uh management
um i did that at sap for a few years
and then had the opportunity to go and
do my mba
post mba um i must say that my
um my joining google in a marketing role
was um
was in a large respect accidental as you
know
like post mba you want to do something
different so initially when
um i was interviewing with google they
wanted me to kind of interview for the
product management ladder at google um
and having done an mba
um you're young and foolish and and you
feel that you want to kind of
do something different and i said look
i've done project management uh before
is there something else that i could do
and uh
the person who was um helping me through
the hiring process she said
there is something called predict
marketing um are you interested in that
and i said yeah why not let's give it a
try
um and that led me to join project
marketing at google um
initially out of london um and i've been
there since as you said it's been 13
plus years now enjoying every minute of
it now
learning still learning which i think is
the most important aspect we all look
for
in our jobs yeah i'm already thinking of
like 20 different ways i want to take
take your your background and your
narrative but i'll focus on just a
couple of those
um one and first i'll park the fact that
um you know so i come from more of a
liberal arts background
and a little more the soft touchy feely
unfortunately i'm you know somewhat
analytical so that helped me get into
marketing
but you you coming from this sort of the
other end all together which is
engineering
and we certainly in our marketing team
have a ton of people who come in for
more of the engineering background
so i think let's park that for a minute
because i think that's an interesting
you know how how one progresses from
that that uh
core skill set and and education uh
versus the other
but i think uh another area that i do
think is sort of interesting is
this uh the difference between product
management and product marketing
and those are often quite distinct
career paths accepting companies of
course like cpg
and and google in your case where you
have sort of that uber
product manager who's essentially a
business line manager
owns the pnl and owns you know kind of
everything
but in your career as you kind of
initially as a more junior
product manager switching over to
product marketing you know what was that
like for you and sort of what were the
skills
you know what you know what were the
skill points that you really have to
focus on
uh to kind of stretch for that new role
yeah so
mark i think um you spot on and saying
that like there is
um different companies approach it
differently but if you were to look at
it broad strokes um
for me and the big difference was in a
product
management role you spend a lot of time
working with engineers
and developers uh to bring
products to life whereas in product
marketing
you do play a role in that initial
development phase
but um i think the real action starts
once you have the semblance of a product
um and you got to bring it to market so
now i always like and there are a lot of
junior folks who often
um have discussions on this topic and
ask okay
what carry a part do i take and i think
it comes down to
um i think it comes down to as you said
like what really interests you right
even though there is overlap like
if what interests you is like the uh the
sausage making of building a product and
like
um understanding a prb and seeing how we
can translate that
bringing a product to life i think um
the product management role um is um
what suits you and the skills that
needed for that are
um are like having a little bit of an
engineering background
deep understanding of where you want to
kind of take your product to
um and ability to again work with
engineers and cross-functional teams
however if you feel that your interest
is um in
taking something to market like in
telling a story and like
taking a product and building a
narrative around it like
uh then um then um you should definitely
consider product
marketing right right and and the skills
that needed for that are
um the ability to kind of look at a
product and and see
how is it a user will perceive it like
what are the real needs of a user that
we are trying to kind of fill
um and then how do you build a story and
narrative around it and get it to market
right right i i i couldn't agree more
that
obviously a lot of things in life it
starts with passion
and uh if you find yourself in a role
and it's drudgery
and it doesn't feel natural then then uh
you know
that those are very important indicators
to pay attention to
um they are uh they do start diverging
pretty quickly i think those two paths
very cool um and particularly in
uh sort of modern um more economic
marketing and acquisition marketing
where
you've got a bunch of discrete skills
whether it's um
you know brand marketing or ppc or
social
um et cetera and so maybe to
talk a little bit more about for you
that evolution
into product marketing um
were you initially responsible for
sort of one subset of disciplines and
you know now obviously you sort of
manage all the above
and kind of how did that evolution go
from you know engineer
product management product marketing
suddenly
you know uh well not sadly but over time
you know
managing all these different disciplines
yeah so um
um the um you are a cmo
i'm running a global company so i think
um you'll relate to this
um at that stage um essentially you're a
generalist like
you need to have like multiple skill
sets in many ways um
um you are not a master of anything uh
um it's more about like team management
and and and like
having an understanding of each
discipline for my uh for my career it's
early on when i did product marketing
the thing that really helped me is that
i come from a technology background so i
was able to leverage that
um i was able to connect with um the
predict folks working on
the one product that i was working on
and
um then um
leverage those skills um what um
the skills that i had at that time was
essentially like i said
a tech background um so most of the work
i did at that stage was
looking at the product understanding the
technology and saying okay
how is it that we can now position it
and get
uh people to use it um post that like i
shifted my focus um on on building our
small business marketing efforts in in
in emea
which is europe middle east and africa
for google and the concept that i needed
there which was
at that time new uh was what he pointed
out acquisition marketing we essentially
wanted to go out and
acquire um or get millions of small
businesses to sign up for google's
products
um and that is a completely new skill
set
um it is what um today is referred to as
um growth marketing
and um uh the thing that helped me there
is that
coming from engineering background um
the analytical side of stuff
interested me and um and that is a
strength that i could bring to the table
but there was a
whole host of stuff that i um i learned
as a part of that opportunity right so
so
and i think um like for folks who
really like seeing a business grow
driving growth
uh that's a fantastic um carrier
opportunity
right sign it and any tech company that
you see around now
you need that skill set how do you take
a product um
and then uh essentially acquire
customers be it like
depending upon the kind of product you
have it could be consumers it could be
small business it could be big
businesses but how do you do it at scale
um
and that was super useful for me uh it
was at that time that i realized that if
you if you look at the marketing
discipline
uh i think there's a product marketing
aspect of it there is the
what i call the growth or analytical
aspect of it
one aspect of the business which or at
least from a marketing point of view
that i felt
um i could learn a little bit more was a
brand um marketing aspect of it right
so so i initially um took on some added
responsibility for driving
um some of the google's consumer
products in emea but then i had an
opportunity to go and set up the
marketing team in india
which is more of a cmo kind of role
where
you need to wear all of the hats and i
would say that i spend a lot of my time
there
in also uh building upon the brand
marketing part of the skill set
because as you grow um to a more senior
role you need to have
all of those skill sets right right
right um i uh i'll confess i'm
uh somebody who's not um
someone who reads business book after
business book
i know some people really uh that's kind
of a thing that they do
but i i have read a couple that i think
are pretty seminal i know
one for for me was called leadership
pipeline
it deals with career progression and
it's kind of takes it all the way
um you know from an individual
contributor and then you know if you're
in a global
corporation literally all the way up to
like a division man you know
uh leader and uh you know all the way up
to president
and one of the interesting concepts is
um
at each stage particularly going from an
individual
contributor to a manager um
how do you um make room
for the people that you manage and it's
you know if you
you most people you know you you reach
that point because
you you've mastered a specific skill and
you be you know you're
recognized as someone who's really great
at whatever
and then and the company sees uh
potential in you and
you're you're leaning in and you've got
all the attributes that they like
and now you're you've got one or two
people beneath me
but i'm used to being the expert who
does everything themselves
and so you know a big milestone is i
need to figure out how to shift some of
that to them
and uh give them the space to fail
uh you give you know give them the
mentorship that they need
and not constantly be kind of coming
back in
and i'll just do the work for you or
i'll just correct you and
um it's sort of a concept that if if you
don't create
more space above someone they'll only
they'll only rise
exactly to the level that you give them
space to yes and then meanwhile
if you're doing that not only you uh you
know not giving them
growth opportunity and not expanding but
then you yourself are not growing
because you're still doing the old role
you used to do
yeah and then yeah to do you have that
experience
absolutely it's a fascinating um it's a
fascinating
point in anybody's career and i've made
my fair share of mistakes um
there right so sir and that is the way
you learn um
and and it's also now as as leaders and
i'm pretty sure you see this as well as
like
you see that play out on a day-to-day
basis you see multiple
extremely smart individuals superstars
at what they do
wanting to grow their skills is wanting
to manage a team you
give a team and they struggle they
struggle because they're so good at
doing something
and and very often i feel that the
reason they struggle is
um is because they overplay their
strengths like you said like
being a manager one of the first things
that's important is you need to step
back
give space but because you're used to
kind of being an individual contributor
being at best of what you do
um the the immediate tendency that you
have is air to micromanage
um and to almost kind of orchestrate
each and every move
and that can be stifling for anybody
right especially for a smart individual
so
um i think it's um it is a process which
um many companies did not invest as much
in and even at google i see that like
that is a big shift we have made over
the years
um earlier it was like as many of us had
in our early carry is back to sun by
fire
um you you manage a team and um
you either burn or you fly uh it's
um it's a pretty uh i would say
learning in the job kind of thing but
nowadays we invest a lot of time
a lot of time at google is now really
spend on
on on mentoring coaching um our
junior or first time people managers to
be good leaders
right so in fact like this whole
repository of
studies we have done um to um to
determine what are the attributes that
make um somebody successful so
you spot on it's um it's something which
um
you need to kind of everything you said
like how do you switch to a mode where
you take a step back give people and
need you
an opportunity to grow understand where
you need to kind of contribute
um stop being an individual contributors
be a people leader
very important transition couldn't
emphasize um
how important it is and and the skills
that you learned there will serve you
extremely well
um as you get more and more people
underneath you and you growing it
heavier
right right the next level is then
you're managing managers
it's a whole nother thing of how do you
again give them enough space but make
sure that
there is um obviously
a goal alignment um and that they
themselves are getting training and so
the things sort of get meta with each
new layer there's sort of meta
management
that ends up happening so yeah maybe
we'll return to that but i think what
might be helpful
so first of all um most of our
um you know our court of core learners
are in their
kind of late 20s to 30s people that are
um you know somewhere three to seven
years into their career
i'm gonna guess that that most of the
hundreds of people that are watching
this are kind of in that range
um so i think a lot of our um discussion
we can
probably angle a little bit more towards
early in the career um
but i think people will be obviously
fascinated to know what
that trajectory looks like and you know
so they can sort of
um you know think ahead and and what may
come
three five ten years from now for them
but i think um
a good point now to sort of give a
little context for everybody if you
don't mind would you go in a little bit
to like your organization itself just so
we get a sense of
and then you know the scope of it and
and
kind of how you divide and conquer
amongst your you know how your team is
set up
yeah so um i i run a global marketing
team
so i have team members um here in um in
the bay area
um in new york um in atlanta uh in
singapore and in india
so um the way um and this is related to
the point that we made earlier right
like there
are like if i were to look across
marketing i feel that um
anybody who um reaches the leadership
stage
has one core area of strength and then
they hire great people who can
supplement the other stuff
you need to have a basic understanding
of the areas but you can't be
a fantastic growth marketer plus a brand
marketer plus a product marketer right
so
and i feel that like that is one of the
things that um
especially early in uh your career take
risks try different things
and then try to find out what is the
area that you really impress you
and invest in that and be a really good
expert in that right
so so if i were to think about my team
and most marketing teams at google
um we each global marketing team has i
would say
um three main functions right so uh we
talked about the first one which is
project marketing
a lot of that is working with product
managers and engineers and trying to
figure out like
how we position a product how do you
take bring a product to life and take it
to market
right so that's the next feature you
need to really
drive growth right like understanding
what
your consumers and users want being
tuned to the market needs
feed that in but really telling a story
about like
what the product is what it stands for
etc right
that is um so we have a fairly large
product marketing team
uh then um comes the second part which
we talked about which is growth
marketing acquisition marketing
and all of our products like be it
google pay
we talked about um android chrome
youtube any google product
there's a bunch of folks who really kind
of obsess about okay so
um and this goes um from country to
country is like
how do you really think about now that
you have a product now that you have a
super egg
how do you grow it like what are the um
i like what are the drivers for growth
like looking at the funnel and all of
that kind of wonderful thing how do you
drive
and growth um by opposing our each and
every pixel like and it's a very very
interesting skill set
uh and um require certain competencies
so
that would be the second big part of the
team and then
the third part is um what we talked
about
i have a brand team which is responsible
for creative development
um which is responsible for um
for almost painting our vision and
telling that story
again like the people who are successful
with that like they're unique
um they are fantastic storytellers they
are big picture thinkers
um and um um they don't obsess about um
like their skill set is not necessarily
in the product marketing or the
uh growth side of stuff their thing is
like how to kind of
um tell a really really compelling story
um
and um that uh is also equally important
so i have a few folks who
focus on that they work with our
agencies and come up with like
really fantastic creative which we can
then deploy
and so so generally speaking you're kind
of across the team divides across the
product acquisition and brand and then
with sub teams
under that's right yes and then at
google what we also do is that we really
like and uh you touched upon it um in
the beginning right which is like
you run a global team but you need to
act locally because
um insights in each market are very
different like what
a consumer needs in india is but um uh
is different from what a consumer needs
and uh let's say
uh the us right and even within these
countries there are differences so
we also invest in building local teams
and we do empower those local teams
the local teams are ultimately the
experts in their country
and are responsible for making sure that
they feed in the requirements from there
but also
launching and deploying campaigns and
countries right
right um and um
local country managers are doing the
hiring for
for the local folks absolutely yes yes
um they are in um so if you look at
global roads like the one i have
um at google we are organized by product
area so
you have a few product areas that you're
responsible for whereas
in a country you essentially are
responsible for like at least as a
country
like a cm of the country which is what i
did in india you're responsible for all
functions
uh and all products in that country so
that i think is the difference between
uh the two roles got it so i i've been
taking a peek we've got a ton of
questions that are coming in
um so and a lot of them are around
um again sort of career paths around
product marketing and career paths
around more acquisition um
so product management and acquisition
marketing
um and so perhaps the way to sort of
tackle this
um there's both your own experience but
maybe also
in your team kind of how you hire and
how the progression would be
for someone on your team who's doing the
more let's start with the more
traditional uh product management
um you know if you're hiring at a sort
of a junior level
you know again sort of the core skill
sets that you're looking for
and then you know what are the important
milestones for somebody
you know based on your own experience or
what you're seeing in your team
let's do that first to make sure we're
getting
a lot of these questions that are coming
out yeah so um
every company has a different hiring
philosophy at google um
one of the things we follow especially
for junior roles is we tend to hire
um what we call athletes right so um
and uh the stuff that we evaluate as
it's not like
one particular marketing skill set but
essentially look at are you a
well-rounded um
um well-rounded person right so uh
are you are you curious do you want to
learn new stuff do you believe in the
power of technology to kind of improve
people's lives
um so the general skills that we look at
you you kind of assess your general
cognitive ability um
you look at how you approach situations
and
uh we also pay a lot of attention to not
just
the what you have done but the how you
do it right
so i cannot emphasize that enough like
um um
like we all want to work with like and
that is one of the reasons i'm still at
google i love
the team that i work with the people i
work with we all want to work with great
people so there's a lot of emphasis on
that like
are you kind of do you have the right
attitude when you work with people
cross-functional leadership is something
which i think everybody should invest in
um early on right so that's how we hire
um i think if i were to look back and um
and
mark you probably relate to this as well
as that um one of the things i would
strongly encourage um
people in the in the five to six years
um range of experience i think that's
the stage where you
you kind of get a feel of what you're
doing you're good at it
you want to grow um do not hesitate to
take
risks i've like if i were to look back
like that's one of the things i would
really really drive home is um it's too
early in your career to kind of decide
like this is
what i want to do right like take risks
try new things
try to kind of um um not worry about
okay if i take that part
will my next promotion be longer right
now i think that we
very often see very junior people
getting obsessed about getting to the
next level etc
the emphasis should be on taking risks
learning new stuff right because
that is what will ultimately help you in
the long term another thing which goes
without saying right so
in our um associate program we have
something um
called um an irrotation so uh one of the
things we do is that
after 18 months of joining the associate
program you are encouraged to take on a
completely new role
and one of the things you are also
encouraged to do it is not just a new
role in a new product area
but actually take a completely different
new role even in a different region
so um um like uh
when you hire leaders um um like in
today's world
one of the things you really really look
for is that not just is it a person who
can execute in one country but
do they have the ability to kind of
understand how different countries
work so i would also encourage people um
and i know that it's easier said than
done and there are various complications
and things
and factors you need to put in play but
takers can also
try to kind of learn from new cultures
try to get experience outside
your comfort zone right right
a lot of what you said certainly rings
true uh to my experience and
and how we approach hiring and simply
learn you know when i think of
um more uh junior to mid-level hires
whether you're a fresher
or somebody three four five years out of
school and
getting into a career you know we all we
all want really smart people
right we want we we want people with um
sort of that raw
raw talent set yes um and and and that's
that's great um we there's sort of a
not really a balance actually i don't
really trade that off terribly much uh
but you know the
new depending on the role i want as much
direct experience as you can get
but um i i find that the
uh the the biggest indicators
for success is
you mentioned it you know the curiosity
like is this somebody
who has really likes puzzle solving
and likes to think multi-dimensionally
about a problem
um and and and absolutely is willing to
take risks which also includes
willing to like ask a question which may
seem stupid
or say based on what i heard i thought
you know
this might be something that's impacting
the business you know that shows that
they're again
kind of holding up that prism and moving
it around and trying to get a sense of
it
and then you know the risk-taking i
think is really interesting because
um you know at sort of a deep
psychological level
it you know some people are are more
fear-based
and you know there's a set you know am i
afraid of the negative
uh consequences yeah and that's a hard
thing to overcome
um bit but fear fear-based and sort of
wanting control
and and wanting to present exactly the
way you want to present
is often very limiting in a career so
you know
if i find it you know with the with the
raw
skills and definitely with the curiosity
and a willingness to engage then you
know that
those those are really great indicators
for me that this is going to be somebody
who's going to be successful now having
said all that
i think where it gets interesting when
we start talking about
you know international teams um or even
diversity which really you know matters
quite a bit
and so there's a lot of cultural
elements that come into that so uh as an
american is
now four years into you know a company
that's uh most of our folks are in india
you know they're very different cultures
and so uh
how how willing you are to engage a
senior person
as our first interview and and you know
riff
it it's uh that gets very tricky for
for both sides of the table because you
know the person is going to be
the most comfortable with me and you
know maybe somebody from directly from
my background
and whether it's in the us and they're
hiring a different ethnicity in the us
or i'm trying to hire
across cultures um you know that's for
me
certainly still an ongoing learning
curve um
and a tricky part of it i don't know if
you've have any sort of magic thoughts
about how you approach somebody who
clearly
comes from a very different background
and who you're trying to kind of break
through
and get a sense of you know how really
do they think and operate
yes that was the point that i think
that's also the biggest skills that you
learn
uh early on by uh working in uh
and interacting with different cultures
so like it's completely indispensable in
today's world right so
um and um and people often
um people often um misunderstand
like the importance of diversity uh the
the real need for diversity is like um
it's only when you have diverse view you
have good ideas um
otherwise uh it's very easy to fall into
your own echo chamber and make mistakes
right so because you've only seen that
side of stuff
um the um
the point that you make is a very
interesting one because um there are
some societal
uh norms uh which uh make
um some things um very interesting like
for example
um i've always been amazed that um when
i have colleagues who
have had an american education how
confident they are and things like
presentations whereas
um for many people um who grew up in the
east including me
that was a learn skill you had to kind
of invest it and learn it
and you see confident what
and like you see that it's very very um
now that i have young kids here who go
to school i see that you start very
early in the us like you have things
like show and tell in school
where you need to take a piece of rock
and explain what it does and you learn
at a very early age
how to do it right so uh and uh which
just kind of builds that confidence
whereas if you don't have that and if
you have a different kind of education
system um
it is uh it is difficult so um
i don't think there is a silver bullet
but i think as managers and people who
are interacting
um and at different levels like rcm
always always tells that
um the the most and even at google like
if you look at it like the
the most senior people the people who
get to take really senior
leadership jobs are not the best
engineers or the best product managers
or the best marketers
uh they could and what they do but the
skill set that they really have is um
what we call cross-functional leadership
ability to work with people in different
backgrounds
have a vision and bring all of them
together right it's not just being the
smartest engineer or
smart marketer it's just having that
skill set and
and and i would use the same bar for uh
for
interacting with somebody from um from a
new culture is like
like leaning on the empathy aspect um
it's easier said than done but
listen and be empathetic and i think
that's and that is something which i've
also learned the hard way right so
you need to invest time and effort in
that
one thing i would add to that
particularly i mean at every stage of
your career
um people's first focus is managing
up yeah so you know what is my what is
my supervisor you know what did my
manager want how do i look good how do i
get things done
and obviously you can't totally flub
that but actually
peer peer collaboration
is massively important and i think you
know i often see that
kind of uh a secondary focus so you know
i'll just make sure
my manager sees me i've got facetime i'm
hitting my goals
and you know maybe i'm kind of ignoring
everyone else and what they need to get
done
but organizationally first of all that's
what really makes the organization work
and over time
you know to build a body of success and
projects that have worked and
all that you know more and more of that
pure collaboration
is is how you grow and grow yeah
betty that's your favorite skill to
learn too yes and you see
like companies like one of the changes
that we've had at google also is like
like
um we've always had 360 degree feedback
extremely important but now um coming
back to the topic that we discussed
earlier especially for managers
we have something called the people
management
report so every people manager is
evaluated
um on a periodic basis by their direct
reports
um and uh we pay and and it's measured
on on the attributes we feel are
important for people leaders at google
and we pay close attention to that right
and in every discussion we have about
promotion giving people
more responsibility etc it's not just
important
because it's exactly the point you said
like people instinctively manage upwards
but if you don't if you don't have the
ability to kind of get your team and
your peers along
you can't get to senior roles like you
just can't because
um we often joke like and and you
probably relate to it like people feel
that
once you get senior you have authority i
actually feel the opposite you don't
have much taught
you have very little authority in fact
right so uh
it's it's about bringing everybody
together um
and and that's a skill set that you need
to invest and learn
right and more and more teams are
cross-functional and yes
initiatives are cross-functional so
you've got to be working on that uh
big time um so um
i i i want to uh sort of drill in a
little bit
on again on sort of progression here
i'm getting sort of questions there so
let's let's
we'll kind of rapid fire this we'll
finish up with product marketing
you know if you think of you know
in the door so we've talked a lot about
you know kind of recruiting and what we
look for in people but
in the door you know that first three
years
getting up to a certain level and then
maybe beginning to manage people
uh in the let's start with first product
marketing
specifics kind of skill sets that people
should be thinking about
um to progress you know that first five
eight
ten years um you know with a couple of
milestones that they come to you
yeah yeah so um we touched upon a few of
those aspects but again like
spend time in understanding your areas
of strength early on in my career i knew
that like i was passionate about
technology
i because of my engineering background
um
i was strong on the analytical side of
the business so that's what i invested
in
and and build a little bit of a
credibility and a reputation for being
good with um analytical marketing um
understanding technology and working
with uh with product and engineering
folks so
uh so i think everybody should spend
some time and really understanding what
is my code strength what do i bring to
the table
like that and um and make sure that
you're really really good at that aspect
um and then of course um once you have
that that's when you then try out new
things stickers
um so that you can broaden your horizons
um the second thing is from a product
marketing perspective
uh i think um and and for all
marketing um um i think one skill set
which is very very very
important as uh is what i call
storytelling like and it's not just from
a creative perspective
um and and i think that is something
which i would encourage people
especially like me who
have a very strong analytical background
to also
uh invest time in learning right like
it's um it's a classic look you have a
product
you might be excited about it but um
there is so much information out there
the person who's going to try your
product has a million other choices
why should they use the particular thing
that
you have to provide to them what's the
story what's the narrative
so for you or for you know team members
how do you help
cultivate that skills is there you know
specific
um research you do or building personas
or
you know whatever you found one or two
things that help people
begin to think about storytelling the um
the phrase that we use at google um
especially for man this is true for any
could be for any technology company and
i would argue for any business in
general is like
the first step is what we call um uh
we have we call it it's a three-step
process know the user
know the magic and connect the two all
right so uh that's what you do uh
essentially in product marketing and
most marketing and
what i mean by that is like invest in
understanding your user base
your consumers your business like who is
using a product understand
provide a deep understanding and this is
not by doing
just a consumer survey right like you
you really need to
leave the life of the user and
understand how they go about it and
there's no better way than
like actually using your product giving
it a run and all that kind of stuff so
be extremely good at knowing the user
because that is important and then
what we say by now the magic is that you
also need to understand the the product
and what you are and what is it that you
want to kind of build the story around
right like
and then the storytelling aspect is
essentially connecting the two like
how do you kind of connect the user who
you have a deep understanding
with the protector offering that you
have right um
and and once you once you get into that
mindset i think
um the storytelling would um would um
come naturally
the other things um which we all um we
all use and
i'm pretty sure um mark this is
something which
um which um you have deployed is
uh it's the power of writing is like uh
very often i feel that we are all in a
rush to kind of long stuff
but and this is again something which
i've learned from very successful people
at google is
um take some time like what's your one
pager like like
and this is not like very often i think
in companies today there's a lot of
emphasis in
making pretty slides but writing things
down putting pen to paper
that's the skillset as well right like
like if you were to have a blog
um blog um or a press release for the
product you're launching
what would it be try writing that
write it down look at it after one week
it'll it'll look it'll seem rubbish
rewrite it uh and then perfect it i
think that
this is uh this is kind of a light
version of amazon jeff bezos
absolutely for people who aren't
familiar with this and amazon
if you're literally at the operating
committee and presenting to jeff
and with a new product idea you get one
single page
to present it and then it's actually all
all oral which is also the way apple
used to always run
um no powerpoint no going what's the
what's bullet point number three it's
gotta all be in your head
so it's kind of a version of that yeah i
think powerpoint very often we all use
like i see powerpoint being users
they're getting
a crunch yes exactly and i like and the
point that you made like i think amazon
takes
the extreme i think they do a fantastic
job with that um
which is like even like three years
before actual product is launched
they they make you write the blog post
of what their launch would look like
right so
i think um that is fantastic
but even if um even if you don't go to
that extreme it's like
for the small area that you're
responsible for it's like
what would it be like what is your one
page right like what's your
um it's the equivalent of what um um
what what uh used to be known as the
elevator pitch like elevated which is
too sharp
but i think um and you can um to a
certain extent just
uh like uh trick that but like
trying to put a one pager is incredibly
difficult right
right right elevator pitch is uh it's
like
amazon but for yeah
so let's let's switch actually probably
to my uh
my my sweet spot which is more the
acquisition marketing and
kind of the same thing as you think
about um again there there's there are
so many
discrete skills um that that's an area
where where often people come in
you know you're a social media person
you're a content person you're a ppce
it's a little bit about um how
you think about entry-level people and
then how those people
start to cross-pollinate and build more
of a you know full-stack marketing
kind of uh skill set and career yeah
look
um all of the unusual pieces that he
called out are important
we are a digital first company that's
what we uh do digital advertising so
um in any campaign that we do we we like
at least the initial part of it is
is completely uh based on digital
advertising right so so
um so we want to make sure that um you
have a basic understanding of
of that um i think
any person in today's world should have
a basic understanding of um
of digital marketing how to use all of
the tools at your disposal be it social
uh be it like ppc and search based stuff
et cetera to drive
um a drive usage and adoption of your
product right so so um
equally important um is um
i think the world has completely made
the switch to um
to the mobile and this is one of the
mistakes i feel that we often make is
that
because a lot of our interactions are
still uh in the real world or over
computers
um we don't spend enough time obsessing
about how small a surface area you have
on a mobile
and how is it that you can um make sure
that your campaigns are
very effective there right so attention
to detail at that level is um
is extremely um important um
the uh the other thing is and um
this is something which um is ingrained
um
to everybody in marketing at google is
like ultimately data speaks we can all
have opinions about what works or not
works
but um once you measure it um
you will have the ability to kind of
understand uh the real deal
and along with that um is um the whole
concept of
making sure that uh you test and i trade
test nitrate we we live and die by that
like like
google is not a company where we wait um
until you have a completely polished
end-to-end product right because
the market moves so quickly so um as
marketers you should have the ability to
kind of launch something
test it and i trade
that is critical that is critical so um
and as as uh again you're learning those
sort of broad skills um you know
google being being in google and also
being
you know a very large corporation um
there's i'm sure lots
lots of lots of internal resources how
much is sort of
formal training uh
you know sort of formal career tracking
part of the progression again from you
know again maybe somebody's starting
with one of these sub disciplines
and wants to you know become a full you
know full stack marketer
or acquisition marketer so um
we have over the years invested in
making sure that
we provide adequate training on the
basics right like how do you build a
good media plan
one of the things that i would emphasize
um as an important skill is that i
definitely did not have it when i joined
google is
how do you write a good brief right i
think um
many marketers i have we find that like
um
you you reach a certain especially mid
level in your career and
you probably write your first brief and
you read it and like um
it's not good enough right so i think
any marketer at least if you if this is
the area if you're passionate about
marketing
you should know how to write a good
brief right so yeah i i i've got i've
gotta
chime in on that too and again i've come
from more of a liberal arts background
and so it's a bit of a bias but but
writing it's not just could i write a
novel if i wanted to change careers but
there's an aspect of it of of really
making sure your thought
process is complete yes
and that's sort of the getting it on
paper and if you can get it on one page
all the best there is um now i do see a
lot
with people who are a little bit more
junior or haven't holy fully hit their
stride
where they've got kind of 70 percent of
the idea down and they think that that's
it and they want to run
and they'd like to have it and then i
could have a chunk of budget to go run
yeah and say you know that's really not
uh
you need to be like 98 thought through
what does that mean who's really the
target what how are you differentiating
et cetera so that's you know writing is
one way to get there because it's
you know if it's all in your head it's
not you know no but nobody can
think through all the the thoughts only
in their head yeah
i think getting that down hey um so i'm
uh
i'm gonna be a little bit more tasky
just because um
i could i could selfishly take your time
for the whole hour plus
and we do have a ton of questions so for
people um
for people out there i i apologize i'm
definitely not gonna get through
everyone's individual ones for sure
because we have literally
about 40 or 50 of them now but i'm gonna
sort of cherry pick ones that um
you know seem representative of what a
lot of you know
various people are asking um
and um so
you know this is a basic one that i
think we covered uh
glenn mary george is uh asking uh
when i attended an interview the
interviewer asked me
um is your role more of marketing or
product marketing is there a difference
between these terminologies
actually i think this is a tricky
question in some respects
um how would you respond to that so
is your role more marketing or product
marketing
yeah look again it's difficult to answer
that without understanding the company
in question because i
have different please approach it but at
a very high level i think
what the interviewers um is um
is trying to kind of ascertain is that
are you a generalist
or have you had um have you had the
ability to kind of
work in building a product to market and
so i think that
is for me the fundamental difference
right
okay good and um so from uh suraj uh
i'll i may take a first crack at this
do we need analytics background to get
into digital marketing space
um analytics is the next buzzword but
how much how essential is it
to to do digital marketing so i'll
preempt you a little bit there
i would say it's absolutely critical
um and um particularly actually so for
me
um i'll take ppc and sem as an example
throughout my many decades particularly
here in silicon valley
um particularly if you went back a
decade plus ago
that was one of the toughest roles to
hire for
particularly somebody who had real um
expertise
i know things have changed now now it
might be uh
you ux you know there's a lot of other
people but still a very tough role
so i would end up um actually hiring
much more
uh junior people in terms of you know
fresh out of college
or only with a couple years uh
engineering background would be actually
a great background
and it was all around are you super
analytical
because because because digital
marketing in particular
is all about funnels it's all about
segments it's all about
n-dimensional analysis of what you've
done
so you know is the creative the right
creative have you done the segmentation
right have you done keyword
um exclusion correctly now are you
bidding correctly
and you can't if you don't have a deeply
analytical mind
um there's some aspects of marketing
like you know content marketing where
maybe it's not quite as analytical
but so that my answer is
you know whether that's formal training
it's certainly to understand
and also i would actually say the
concept of web analytics
and you know whether it's google
analytics it's a great place to start
and or even finish but but general
concepts about web analytics which gets
you to page by page what's on a page
uh you know what's a progression you
know what's what's the lead action what
are the events
time series having having a real
familiarity with web analytics
is a foundation that would help you in
anything related to digital marketing
yes couldn't agree more i think it was a
uh
like a very very comprehensive and and
very often um
if you don't get the funnel right
there's no point spending money on
marketing right because we have a leaky
bucket
and we've all made a mistake right so
which is why it's so important as you
said
to get the analytical part of it right
right
all right good so uh from edmond i just
had the digital marketing specialist
certification from simply learn thank
you edmund
i studied ppc social media digital
analytics seo
i find it difficult to decide which area
to focus
um uh should i start doing all of it
um or or how do i focus so again
everybody's
question is is you know in some cases
very idiosyncratic
um my i won't preempt you all the way
through here but i you know i think the
two things to think about
three things one follow your bliss
there's an area where you just naturally
find yourself spending more time digging
a little deeper
not walking away from your desk and you
know take that
indicator to heart the second is you
know depending on
what geography and what you're seeing
out in the market
it's certainly okay to start doing
interviews
across companies that could be for any
number of those roles at an entry point
if you don't have
deep experience and kind of get the
feedback uh
and then then it could be as much about
do you are you interested in the
company that's got the role that you
want and then thirdly that you
see a sort of a progression out of that
whatever that initial role is
so and sandeep i don't know if you would
add to that
again i'm not much to add here you said
it like understand what energizes you
like
and of course you need to match that
with the opportunities out there because
if it doesn't energize and excite you
you're not going to be good at it right
so um you're not going to give your
hundred percent
so um that is what you should focus on
all right good so um this is from uh
um and uh it's a long one but it's a
good one it's basically about where
where digital marketing is going
uh you know we got mobile we got
artificial intelligence we got
uh automation robotic etc
um you know so this is a broad very
broad and really good question
but let's take sort of a three to five
year
uh time horizon and i guess both in
terms
of things like the tool sets like you
know martech and how martech is changing
or new platforms
you know or court for fundamental things
like ar vr
are there things that are already done
deep on your radar and that your team's
already beginning
to think about or are actually changing
some of their practices
your practices yeah so um great question
um like a couple of uh and this is
in no particular order but um a couple
of things that come to mind is that
i do feel that increasingly the um both
ai and ml will have a profound effect on
all fields across the um
world um and definitely in marketing
right so
um we are um uh we are definitely using
that
especially in terms of creative testing
creative suggestions
how do you kind of have like large scale
multivariate testing how can you kind of
learn and understand what growth
strategies work best
so rather than a marketer sitting and
like drawing
out each and every possible scenario
like like what is the right amount of
incentive you have for driving um the
perfect cpa right so
uh you could run like 50 tests for it or
you could have an algorithm which has
the um
which has which is a ml to kind of
quickly come to optimal solution right
so i think those things um are
definitely going to happen
uh the by the way on that one i i
actually think that that
for someone early in their career is
um is a two-sided coin because
there are is a lot of learning that
happens from doing things manually
if you're 22 or 24
and coming into a particularly uh you
know um
a leader like a google clearly is going
to be you know in their own marketing
leader and deploying this stuff and you
just got a black box and you just hit
the button
and the button says that you know use
that creative or doesn't even tell you
it just does it for you
you're actually not going to learn those
core skills
yes and so it's actually a bit of a
challenge like for people right now
don't wait for the black box you you you
want to understand
like the basic concept that the black
box is is is optimizing for
because otherwise it's all going to be
very abstract to you
exactly and like i also feel that like
you can have the smartest machine but
it's garbage and garbage out right so
you
need to know you can have the smartest
algorithm but you know if you don't know
the fundamentals of marketing and
um multivariate testing and like what
you want to get out of it
i think you won't be able to um get the
most out of it
right so very fair yeah
um ar any other kind of things you know
you know i guess again this is a very
personal view i do feel that it will
fundamentally change
uh but um very often um
and for folks like us who are in the
technology industry
part of the challenge is how do you um
like our um like sergey who is one of
the google founders
often used to say that like uh people
often overestimate in the short term
the importance of a technological trend
and completely underestimate in the long
term right so
um and i think um vr is a good example
of that
uh you see all of these and and again
the fintech world
with blockchain and etc another probably
example um
these things will have profound
implications on how people do stuff
uh but um it's very important also for
folks early in your career
not to have the urge to change the what
i call quote unquote the
new sexy thing um because
uh you feel oh there's this new shiny
thing which i want to kind of do
i hear vr is cool so let me just go and
try to do vr
like this is the urge i think all of
these technologies will have profound
impact in our lives in the years to come
but um sometimes you do need to kind of
give
um a technology um um
some um some room to grow um uh mark
munson
um you know this example like people
often talk about a successful iphone
launch but
nobody and talks about the fact that
about 15 years before that
they tried an apple drive with newton
and um
probably ahead of its times right so uh
so i feel that we are in that space now
when it's like um
um in some of these technologies but
absolutely
uh they will have an effect
yeah yeah i agree with all that so um uh
and i i don't know if we will probably
go a couple minutes over if that's okay
with you
um i think an area that every everyone
would also
be interested in and um and again i know
people have a lot of sort of specific
career questions and i apologize that we
won't
get to a lot of these but um part of
your role in your team's role around
payments
i would be interesting to get your
perspective
on uh you know distributed ledger
blockchain
and kind of you know kind of very
briefly how that
is actually you know coming to life
um in in at least the payment space
and then to the extent that that is at
all kind of rippling through your
marketing team and
how they approach marketing um i think
that might be
i think it's related to um it's related
to what we
uh discussed earlier like and mark you
and i have had a brief chat about this
before as well
if you put a look at technology and um
all of the areas that technology is
impacted it's completely changed how you
buy stuff it's completely changed how do
you navigate around this world
it's completely changed how we consume
media um
technology especially mobile and
internet is completely
um and software has completely changed
and a variety of ways in which we
do things two areas
and this is not because uh we are in
that space two areas i fundamentally
feel where
um there is so much more technology can
do one
and and i think the covet pandemic is
actually exciting it is online learning
education um definitely a lot more
technology can do in that area
and the second is um is fundamentally uh
money
and that is what we are working on uh
like
yes there have been innovations in the
past but
um i often relate to the stage that we
are in people still use
um paper money right so um it is very
similar to if you if you think about
like
you had maps um uh paper maps for
millennia and it's very difficult to
explain to
uh young folks now how we used to
navigate from one place to the other
using paper maps and and stuff like that
right and while driving wow on the
steering wheel
yeah yes and and like um
essentially what google and other
companies did is that you got like
mapping data which was offline you
bought it online and then you applied
smarts to it right so so
um and and and you put data into it and
like
uh if you think about a lot of the
things that you see now like even things
like driverless cars and companies like
uber lyft
they're all based on that fundamental
digitization of
geographic data i think there is a
similar
um actuating trend towards completely
digitizing money
yes wire transfer and stuff like that
has been there for ages but
the power of um applying technology to
money will profoundly change people's
lives that is what i'm excited about
what i do now and what my team's work is
um
great stuff well um i i think we should
commit to doing this every thursday i've
got about another 10 hours of
conversation to do we barely got through
uh some of the questions
um i certainly hope for all those that
have joined us that this has
been useful i know i've i've had a great
time and uh
we could go on and on for for several
more hours
um but sandeep we really appreciate your
time
uh and excited to see what you and your
team are
going to do over the next couple of
years and look forward to using some
more of those
google products thank you thank you i
really enjoyed the conversation
and um i hope um i hope the participants
also enjoyed it
as soon as i did great thank you
everyone so much
foreign and before you log off i'd like
to mention to everybody that
we have another webinar next thursday
september 24th
uh leadership webinar how to become an
empowered engineer with avatar aurora
vice president of engineering at
salesforce
and we hope that you or your engineering
colleagues will
join us for that take care
and this concludes our webinar today
you